escenas como esta se repiten
habitualmente los bancos libaneses ante
la desesperación de los depositantes de
no poder disponer de sus ahorros el 4 de
octubre la diputada Cintia zaraccir tuvo
que recurrir a la fuerza para retirar su
dinero retenido necesario para pagar un
tratamiento médico se encerró con su
cómplice el abogada dinabusur en la
oficina bancaria hasta que obtuvo la
suma para los gastos médicos no nos
dejan otra opción No me arrepiento de lo
que hicimos fue un acto de humanidad
Cintia padece una enfermedad Crónica y
por fin ha sido operada y se está
recuperando mientras la situación no
cambia seguirá habiendo más
allanamientos el bufete abogados
legales de los depositantes y
ahorradores libaneses nuestros ahorros
están atrapados desde hace tres años en
los bancos no hay una visión o
estrategia para la recuperación
económica del Líbano es una reacción
natural la gente quiere su dinero los
llevaneses no ven mejoría en la
situación económica ahora que el
parlamento libanés intenta pasar una la
ley de control de capitales la ira de
los depositantes crece en las calles
Richard faraón tenía la mayor productora
de eventos en el Líbano
el capital no vamos a dejar que la ley
de control de capitales sea aprobada
nuestros gobernantes quieren acabar con
nosotros matar la economía destruir el
país el correcto puesto por los bancos
que limita el retiro de efectivo a 100
dólares semanales sumado al cierre
indefinido de la sucursales bancarias
tras la ola de asaltos ha llevado a cada
vez más libaneses a recurrir a la
criptomoneda para poder pagar sus
compras y recibir remesas extranjeras
nosotros damos una alternativa confiable
a la gente corriente para que puedan
disponer de recursos a través de
nuestros servicios de cripto carteras
digitales
somos después de Turquía el país de
oriente medio con más transacciones de
criptomoneda
el país está asumido en la peor crisis
financiera de su historia si mejores
perspectivas para el futuro y sin
gobierno el Líbano no podrá recibir los
tan necesitados 3.000 millones de
dólares de ayuda del fondo monetario
internacional para al rescate financiero
y los ciudadanos seguirán sin poder
acceder a sus ahorros